damit es schneller geht die
gesundheitsminister wollen die hausärzte
ins boot holen ab april
wann buchen wo buchen was buchen
viele sind ratlos die tourismusbörse
will das geschäft trotzdem wieder in
schwung bringen und der
weltmeister-trainer geht aber wer kommt
joachim löw will nur noch bis zur em im
sommer bundestrainer bleiben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara l genannt und willkommen schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch norbert
lehmann für den sport einen schönen
guten tag von mir in sachen corona impft
tempo ist deutschland bisher eher eine
schnecke andere länder sind deutlich
schneller
nun will die politik den turbo
einschalten vizekanzler scholz sprach
von bis zu 10 millionen impfungen pro
woche in zukunft noch sind wir davon
weit entfernt
seit weihnachten haben hierzulande mehr
als 5,3 millionen menschen die erste
spritze erhalten das sind 6,4 prozent
der bevölkerung etwa zweieinhalb
millionen haben auch die zweite dosis
bekommen und damit den vollen impfschutz
das sind 3,9 prozent um den pakt zu
erhöhen sollen ab april auch hausärzte
flächendeckend impfen
patricia schäfer impfen beim hausarzt
wie hier in brandenburg wird das bereits
gemacht allerdings nur im rahmen von
pilotprojekten um zu sehen wie es
funktioniert
im berchtesgadener land haben auf diesem
weg bereits 1000 über 80-jährige eine
impfung in der praxis bekommen
die meisten älteren leute sind froh wenn
sie nicht ins impfzentrum müssen wir
scharren mit den hufen
ich sehe auch jeden tag in den medien
england israel da wird bei ikea geimpft
war denke ich wir auch das können wir
doch auch also wenn man uns lässt dann
glaube ich würde das wahnsinnig schnell
gehen die aufwendige dokumentation
bremst den im betrieb redundante fragen
und zusätzliche papiere
das kostet zeit nicht nur die hausärzte
auch betriebsärzte könnten ins impfen
mit einsteigen
hunderte unternehmen haben das bereits
angeboten
die allianz will dafür bis zu 25
impfstraßen in ihren niederlassungen
einrichten wir denken zusätzlich auch
darüber nach den angehörigen der
mitarbeiter dieses angebot zu machen
insgesamt geht es etwa um 40.000
mitarbeiter die wir in einer impfung
ungefähr in vier bis sechs wochen
durchgeimpft haben möchten
dafür müsste die corona im verordnung
geändert werden mehr spielraum in der
verordnung wünschen sich auch
ärztevertreter
dass ich selber entscheiden kann welche
patientinnen und patienten aufgrund des
von mir identifizierten risikos eines
schweren oder sehr schweren
krankheitsverlauf ist von mir festgelegt
werden und ich die patienten
entsprechend in maine im konzept
einbinden können ob die ärzte mehr
entscheidungsspielraum bekommen
darüber wollen die gesundheitsminister
morgen beraten
besonders hoch sind nach wie vor die
infektionszahlen im vogtlandkreis in
sachsen und jetzt reagiert die
landesregierung sie will die impf
reihenfolge aufheben damit sich jeder in
der region impfen lassen kann
die sieben tage inzidenz liegt im
vogtlandkreis bei 200 51,3 der
durchschnittswert für ganz sachsen wird
vom robert koch institut mit 84
angegeben
cornelia schiemenz in dresden was
bedeutet dieser schritt ja das bedeutet
dass sachsen einmal mehr nach vorn
prescht die hohen inzidenz zahlen in den
grenzregionen hier eben vor allen dingen
im vogtlandkreis die sollen so gebrochen
werden wie es heißt soll es noch nicht
gleich morgen losgehen aber ganz
bestimmt in den nächsten tagen dann wird
die impf priorisierung aufgehoben und
jeder der 18 ist und es möchte darf sich
eben dann impfen lassen
das wirft probleme auf uns hat das
deutsche rote kreuz gesagt dass sie
bislang erst mal noch gar nichts davon
wissen
und auch noch unklar ist wie man auf die
schnelle die vielen impfdosen beschaffen
könnte und zum anderen befürchtet man
einen massenansturm und appelliert schon
an die bürger bitte nicht sofort in die
impfzentren im vogtlandkreis zu stürmen
möglich macht das ganze vorgehen ein
passus im beschluss der
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidentin und vom vergangenen
mittwoch da haben
michael kretschmer und markus söder
darauf gedrängt dass eine so genannte
hot spot regel aufgenommen wurde
nun muss der bund die impfverordnung
entsprechend ändern das soll am
donnerstag passieren und dann könnte es
eigentlich schon relativ schnell
losgehen und damit wäre eben dann auch
der erste damm gebrochen für eine
aufweichung der bislang starre nimmt
priorisierungen interessante
informationen dankeschön cornelia
schiemenz
jetzt der blick auf den bundesweiten
infektionszahlen das robert koch
institut bildet 4252 neue infektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden das sind 309
mehr als vergangenen dienstag 255
menschen starben in verbindung mit cupid
die inzidenz ist leicht gesunken und
liegt jetzt bei 67,5 überraschend heute
eine neue studie zu corona danach erhöht
starker pollenflug das infektionsrisiko
im moment liegt etwa blütenstaub von der
erde und der haselnuss in der luft und
das ist nicht nur für allergiker
problematisch denn je mehr um hersch
wird desto mehr menschen könnten sich
mit corona infizieren
der anstieg betrug bis zu 20 prozent
grund der pollenflug schwächt die
abwehrkräfte gegen das virus brigitte sa
hat mehr
die temperaturen steigen die natur
erwacht und das ist ein problem
forscher der tu münchen haben pollen
daten von messstationen aus 31 ländern
und die infektionszahlen ausgewertet
ihre erkenntnis fliegen viele pollen
durch die luft gibt es mehr corona fälle
wenn der vollen auf die schleimhaut
oberfläche trifft dann setzt der
substanzen frei die wir bisher noch
nicht identifiziert haben und diese
substanzen greifen in den signalweg ein
die substanzen aus den pollen sorgen
dafür dass vorübergehend weniger
botenstoffe gebildet werden die das
immunsystem sonst anregen gegen
eingedrungene viren zu kämpfen gibt es
weniger botenstoffe können sich corona
viren im körper leichter vermehren wenn
man draußen mit pollen in verbindung
kommt dann ist dieser effekt für die
nächsten drei tage da die schleimhäute
werden gelähmt und das ist natürlich
gerade für die menschen gefährlich die
sowieso ein erhöhtes risiko haben sich
anzustecken
konkret haben die wissenschaftler
errechnet 100 pollen pro kubikmeter luft
erhöhen die korona infektionsrate im
schnitt um vier prozent
in manchen deutschen städten werden in
spitzenzeiten 500 pollen pro kubikmeter
gemessen
das bedeutet 20 mia corona infektionen
umweltfaktoren und corona ein bislang
kaum beleuchtet das thema immerhin auch
hier gilt es geht zwei maske tragen
hilft gegen das virus und gegen polen
wir alle sind deutschland das ist das
ziel so die worte der bundeskanzlerin
heute beim integrationsgipfel aber wir
hätten noch sehr sehr viel zu tun um die
vielen vorurteile aufzudecken
vor 15 jahren hatte merkel diesen gipfel
ins leben gerufen diesmal trafen sich
die 120 teilnehmer krone bedingt online
mathis feldhoff
es ist das dreizehnte mal dass sich
regierung und gesellschaftliche gruppen
über integrationspolitik unterhalten ein
erkenntnis defizit hat man inzwischen
nicht mehr
jetzt geht es dann eigentlich auch
wirklich darum diese ganzen pläne in die
praxis strukturell umzusetzen so dass
sie selbstverständlich in der
gesellschaft werden doch es gibt auch
das hässliche gesicht von deutschland
gewalttätige und rassistische angriffe
das muss auch die kanzlerin eingestehen
wenn ich nur an von nsu bis hanau denke
dann ist das nicht so einfach für
jemanden der zum beispiel aus der also
türkischstämmig ist zu glauben dass man
hier die gleiche
willkommen haid hat und die gleichen
möglichkeiten hat über 100 maßnahmen von
integrationskursen bis zur bekämpfung
des rassismus soll in deutschland zu
einem modernen einwanderungsland machen
zusammen hat kann nur gut stattfinden
wenn wir von einander gute informationen
bekommen wenn von wenn wir von einander
auch bereit sind zu lernen
es gibt die guten vorbilder ugur sahin
den gründer von biontech die nrw
staatssekretärin sehr agiler oder die
wissenschaftsjournalistin meint kim
doch auch alle anderen oft weniger
privilegiert müssten die gleichen
chancen haben integration hat es schwer
gerade jetzt die pandemie kann die
bestehenden konflikte in unserer
gesellschaft noch vertiefen denn meine
große sorge ist dass durch den lange
ausgefallenen schulunterricht die
bestehenden sprachlichen defizite sich
noch vertieft haben könnten und deshalb
brauchen wir nicht heute hingibt sondern
taten
demnächst will die bundesregierung den
begriff rasse aus dem grundgesetz
streichen das sei auch ein beitrag für
mehr gemeinsamkeit in deutschland es
geht um propaganda lügen verleumdungen
eine studie der eu sieht deutschland als
hauptziel russische desinformation mehr
als 700 mal hätten russische medien
falsche informationen über deutschland
verbreitet moskau spricht von so
wörtlich lächerlichen vorwürfen
außenminister maas erklärte die angriffe
zielten darauf ab vertrauen in die
demokratie insgesamt auszuhöhlen
größer die erleichterung als sich die
usa wieder dem internationalen kampf
gegen die erderwärmung anschlossen eine
der ersten amtshandlungen des neuen
präsidenten beiden war jahr zurück ins
pariser klimaschutzabkommen und er
setzte john kerry als klimabeauftragten
der kam heute nach brüssel und forderte
direkt mehr ehrgeiz
das werde viel geld kosten sei aber
billiger als nichts zu tun
stefan leifert über einen neustart nur
der handschlag fehlt ansonsten ist alles
ein bisschen wie früher ein echtes
treffen und echte sympathien zwischen
und usa john kerry kommt mit der
botschaft nach brüssel das usa und eu
beim klimaschutz vor ihrer letzten
chance stehen die klimakonferenz von
glasgow ende des jahres wird unsere
letzte chance und hoffnung dass die welt
zusammen kommt und dass paris abkommen
weiterentwickelt paris alleine reicht
aber nicht mehr selbst wenn wir alles
erfüllt was wir in paris vereinbart
haben würde die erderwärmung immer noch
3,7 grad oder mehr betragen
es war eine der ersten amtshandlungen
joe biden die usa wieder ins pariser
klimaabkommen zu holen und plötzlich hat
washington es eilig drängt europa zu
noch mehr ehrgeiz bei den klimazielen
äthiopiens wir uns als europäer es
bewusst dass wir unseren beitrag leisten
müssen für das gemeinsame ziel aber auch
dass wir es nicht alleine schaffen
können sie als usa an unserer seite zu
haben als freund und verbündeten ist
enorm wichtig für ihn nur mit importen
kreis doch mit der beiden regierung
werden die usa auch zu konkurrenten
europas im rennen der industrie um
klimafreundliche technologien die usa
sagt jetzt wir machen mit und das ist
eigentlich gut weil jetzt haben wir
einen ein wettrennen dorthin wer als
erster klimaneutral wird und da muss
sich europa jetzt anstrengen eu und usa
versprechen eine neue ära beim
klimaschutz im transatlantischen
verhältnis irgendwann dann auch wieder
mit handschlag kein tag ohne proteste
gegen den putsch in myanmar kein tag
ohne brutale gewalt des militärregimes
und das seit mittlerweile fünf wochen
immer öfter schießt die polizei mit
scharfer munition mehr als 60 menschen
sollen bereits getötet worden sein
über den aufstand gegen die hinter
normen odenthal
die verzweiflung im gesicht und doch von
hoffnung getragen dass vernunft einkehrt
nicht schießen fleht die nonne an rosa
nutzung
doch im selben moment habe sie gespürt
dass sie die gewalt nicht aufhalten kann
erklärt sie später wir sollten uns
gegenseitig helfen unterstützen aber den
sicherheitskräften kann man nicht trauen
sie holen sich wen sie wollen sie
prügeln und sie töten
yang gon mandala mit china dabei überall
im land durchkämmen polizei und militär
offenbar gezielt die straßen überall im
land werden tote und verletzte gemeldet
tag für tag das ausland kritisiert
verurteilt die gewalt mehr nicht in uno
sicherheitsrat gilt china als
mächtigster blockiere
der außenminister betonte peking stehe
auf keiner seite habe auch mit der
abgesetzten demokratischen regierung gut
zusammengearbeitet
seinen hinweis man halte am
partnerschaftlichen kurs fest egal wie
die situation sich entwickeln könnte man
jedoch auch als freibrief für das
militär dort an rosa new dawn ist zurück
an der kampflinie die schwester lässt
nichts unversucht einer nonne und zwei
polizisten begegnen sich auf knien ein
gebet leise hoffnung vielleicht
wenigstens für einen moment
wer wird der nächste präsident von
brasilien bei den wahlen im kommenden
jahr deutet sich ein brisantes duell an
der frühere präsident lula da silva darf
wieder kandidieren
vor drei jahren hatte er in allen
umfragen geführt als mehrere korruptions
urteile ihn aus dem wahlkampf warfen die
wurden jetzt völlig überraschend
aufgehoben
damit könnte der sozialist lula gegen
seinen erzfeind den rechtsradikalen
amtsinhaber bordeaux antreten
selten war die sehnsucht nach
tapetenwechsel und reisen größer aber
auch die unsicherheit was wann wo geht
vor ostern etwa es noch völlig unklar ob
überhaupt reisen möglich sein werden
quarantäne droht ohnehin deshalb wissen
38 prozent der deutschen noch gar nicht
ob sie dieses jahr das risiko eingehen
wollen
auf der internationalen tourismusbörse
will die branche
machen den kunden und sich selbst
carsten behrendt eine urlaubs hoffnung
der reisebranche heißt mittelmeer
griechenland türkei spanien schon ab
ostern plant tui wieder erster mallorca
reisen auch deutschland mit vielen
schnell erreichbaren zielen bleibt im
trend
in die türkei wir haben träume als
trainiert mit müh und not
und diesmal wird das risiko nicht mal
ein von außen unsichtbar läuft seit
heute in berlin die wichtigste
tourismusmesse tb als reine
fachkonferenz im internet die deutschen
anbieter hoffen für dieses jahr auf 50
prozent des vorkrisen umsatzes große
pleiten konnten bislang verhindert
werden
das angebot ist in dem maße relativ
schnell verfügbar in dem maße wie reisen
auch wieder ermöglicht wird und da geht
es um quarantäne regelungen die das
reisen vielfach auch bei den kunden
verhindern
deshalb fordern wir auch auf und fordern
eine ablösung der quarantäne regelung
das heißt mehr corona tests dafür
weniger risikogebiete und quarantäne für
reisebüro chefin daniela man wäre das
ein gutes mittel gegen zu nehmendes
fernweh wollen einfach also eher haus
aus ihrem alltag
ziel sind im moment gar nicht wichtig
sondern wirklich einfach nur weg hier
einen tipp hat sie noch flex tarife und
pauschalreisen können vorchor ohne
stress schützen dann gibt's wenigstens
geld zurück wenn es wieder nichts werden
sollte mit der traumreise und es gibt
neues aus dem zerstrittenen britischen
königshaus der buckingham palace hat
sich offiziell geäußert die königin
nehme die rassismus vorwürfe von prinz
harry und seiner frau megan sehr ernst
und die ganze familie sei traurig zu
erfahren in welchen schwierigkeiten sich
das paar gefunden habe die beiden waren
in einem viel beachteten interview im us
fernsehen aufgetreten
darin beklagten sie rassistische
anspielungen im königspalast außerdem
sei ihre bitte nach psychologischer
unterstützung ignoriert worden
jetzt die sport nachricht des tages
norbert jogi löw mag nach der em im
sommer nicht mehr bundestrainer sein
schon überraschend oder auf jeden fall
überraschend aber auch irgendwie typisch
läuft er entscheidet wann schluss ist
nicht andere nach der wm pleite in
russland 2018 und jüngst dem 0 6-debakel
gegen spanien da wackelte sein stuhl
aber löw fühlt sich ein nachfolger ist
noch nicht benannt
die ankündigung eines weltmeister
trainers liegt überraschend auf den
ersten blick auf den zweiten wie eine
befreiung für joachim löw ich gehe
diesen schritt ganz bewusst von der
stolz mit riesiger dankbarkeit
gleichzeitig aber weiterhin mit einer
ungebrochenen großen motivation was das
bevorstehende em turnier angeht nach dem
wm-desaster in russland baut löw seine
mannschaft um dann kommt die panini und
das 0 6 in spanien eine historische
niederlage
beratung folgen läuft bleibt kämpferisch
aber informationen die nach außen
dringen zeigen ein
kommunikationsdesaster auf da herrscht
vielleicht auch explosionsgefahr
bei mir läuft ein projekt typ der machen
durfte was ihm vorschwebte
die kritik wird stärker als löw spieler
wie boateng müller und hummeln 2009/10
aussortiert für seinen neuanfang aber
während seiner mannschaft abbaut kommt
das trio in der bundesliga wieder in
form
für die em will jetzt doch alle türen
offen lassen welche spielertypen
brauchen wir was brauchen wir auf den
einzelnen positionen um den
größtmöglichen erfolg zu garantieren
löws nachfolger jürgen klopp stand jetzt
nicht ein ich werde in oder nach diesem
sommer waren auch immer das würde ich
nicht als bundestrainer als mögliche
bundes zur verfügung stellen wenn jobs
einer der hoch gehandelt wird bleibt
hansi flick voraussetzungen er will und
bayern ließen ihn zu alten freunden
gehen ja und noch eine wichtige
nachricht für die deutschen fußball-fans
bei der heim-em 2024 laufen alle spiele
im free-tv im zdf in der ard und bei rtl
so die vereinbarung zwischen den drei
sendern und dem rechteinhaber deutsche
telekom insgesamt 34 spiele bei ard und
zdf darunter alle deutschen begegnungen
das eröffnungsspiel sowie die halbfinals
und das
finale dazu eine umfassende nach
verwertende berichterstattung aller 51
spiele auf sämtlichen plattformen im
gegenzug erwirbt die deutsche telekom
verwertungsrechte an der kommenden
europameisterschaft und der
weltmeisterschaft 2022 die aber auch in
gewohntem umfang bei ard und zdf zu
sehen sein werden über die für beide
seiten faire vereinbarung freue ich mich
sehr
damit kommen wir unserem publikum die
höhepunkte die attraktivsten spiele der
heim-em 20 24 im frei empfangbaren
fernsehen zeigen sicher doch für alle
fußballfans und für die beitragszahler
eine gute nachricht also die heim-em
2024 ein programmhighlight bei ard und
zdf
freuen wir uns drauf das wasser nicht
dankeschön noch ist ruhe vor dem sturm
wann der wind zulegt sagt uns gleicher
stelle beim wetter viertel vor zehn ist
heute journal zeit mit marietta slomka
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen einen unbeschwerten abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es deutet sich ein
wetterumschwung an und zwar erreichte
uns dann zum donnerstag ein sturmtief
und das ist zunächst noch auf dem
atlantik kommt dann weiter vorwärts und
wird am donnerstagvormittag dann
teilweise für heftige böen sorgen teilt
im orkanartigen bereich dazu gleich mehr
wir schauen erst mal in die nacht und da
gibt es im südosten regen und schnee
inklusive glätte nach westen hin bildet
sich nebel sonst klart es auf und dann
sinken die temperaturen im osten auf
minus ein bis minus 8 grad ganz im
westen deutschlands auf plus drei grad
morgen im tagesverlauf lässt regen und
schnee im südosten nach sonst gibt es
viel sonne vor allem richtung oder und
neiße von westen her drängen neue wolken
ins land und der wind dreht allmählich
auf süd bis südwest und frischt weiter
auf und dann ist auch regen dabei zum
späten nachmittag und abends ansonsten
ist es im süden teils sogar nur
freundlich die temperaturen steigen auf
4 bis 11 grad und im südwesten auf 12
grad
ja am donnerstag geht es zur sache im
nordwesten deutschlands teils
orkanartige böen verbreitet sturmböen
und dazu kräftiger regen bei 8 bis 14
grad
ein schöner